[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouvez
l'actualité du jour à l'assemblée cette
et l'audition du patron de total patrick
pouyanné s'est fait cuisiner par les
députés sur les super profits du
pétrolier français faut-il ou non les
taxer au nom de la solidarité nationale
en ces temps de crise les socialistes
veulent déclencher un référendum l'année
ps déposera des amendements au budget
nous en débattrons notre grand témoin ce
soit c'est bernard cazeneuve l'ancien
premier ministre marquer la rentrée
politique en lançant un manifeste pour
une gauche sociale démocrate non
soumises à jean luc mélenchon il va même
jusqu'à lancer un mouvement politique
loin du ps et de la cnu baisse nous en
parlerons avec lui et puis 2 a franchi
ce soir deux partis pris fanny guinochet
pour l'économie attention la réforme de
l'assurance chômage arrive à l'assemblée
et elle va cliver et puis un nouveau
visage mohamed sifaoui sur cette petite
musique qui monte sur le boycott du
mondial de foot au qatar voilà pour
mieux ce soir
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs qui a dit que le clivage
droite gauche avait disparu s'il ya un
débat qui prouve le contraire c'est bien
celui ci on va parler ce soir de la
taxation des supers profits avec trois
députés qui ont tous très attentivement
écouté patrick pouyanné à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui rené cazeneuve bonsoir
chemin et merci d'être avec nous députés
renaissance du gers rapporteur général
du budget c'est l'un des rôles clés dans
le débat budgétaire qui arrive à
l'assemblée et qui évidemment être
sensible parce que cette question de la
taxation des supers profits va s'inviter
dans ce débat christine piras bonne
bienvenue sur ce plateau bonsoir à vous
bonsoir vous êtes député socialiste du
puy de dôme membres de la nuque baisse
et de cette mission flash à l'assemblée
sur les super profits qui auditionnait
donc le patron de total ce matin le ps
qui va par ailleurs
déclenché la procédure du rip sur le
sujet le référendum d'initiative
populaire prévu par la constitution ça
mérite une explication ni reviendra tout
à l'heure jean philippe tanguy bonsoir à
vous soit et bienvenue sur ce plateau
député rassemblement national de la
somme également un membre de cette
mission flash sur les super profits des
entreprises gazières et pétrolières
on va planter le décor tout de suite
avant de vous donner la parole quai pour
qui est contre cette taxe sur les
super-profits c'est vous qui vous est
collé comme chaque soir stéphane si j'ai
bien compris stéphane blakowski et 8,1
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane bonsoir à tout bonsoir
à tous si j'ai bien compris ce soir et
ben si j'ai bien compté madame en kawa
la guerre en ukraine ça fait pas que des
malheureux cet hiver ils acquerront
froid et pendant ce temps là et la route
qu'ils seront bien au chaud et qu'il se
mette de l'argent plein les poches non
mais c'est la vérité c'est malheureux
évidemment kawa mais quand il ya une
guerre il ya toujours des profiteurs en
profitent alors je vous parlais un peu
sentencieux peut-être mais je ne suis
pas le seul à le dire écoutez nous avons
des gens qui ont spéculé sur la guerre
et aujourd'hui vous avez des gens qui
font beaucoup d'argent sur la guerre
on appelle ça des profiteurs de guerre
et moi je ne comprends pas comment on
peut accepter très longtemps que
l'argent du contribuable dans nos pays
soient utilisés à aider les ménages à
pouvoir vivre en temps de guerre et qu'à
côté de ça il ya des gens qui
s'enrichissent beaucoup en temps de
guerre donc on va devoir régler ça alors
la question c'est comment régler ça
peut-être qu'ils sont les profiteurs de
guerre dont parle à emmanuel macron
crois que c'est là qu'il a eu un petit
malentendu par rapport au temps que jean
paul ier tout à l'heure parce que c'est
pas du tout ça en fait à mon avis quand
il a parlé de profiteurs de guerre le
président il visait plutôt les
producteurs de pétrole opep ils
voulaient pas les nommer pour pas se
fâcher avec eux on va pas se fâcher avec
des produits lors de pétrole mais du
coup on s'est dit mais qui sont ces
mystérieux profiteurs de guerre on a
commencé à chercher à ce niveau prenons
total par exemple total de 100 milliards
de chiffre d'affaires première
entreprise française on en est fiers
mais en même temps un peu profité de la
guerre totale regarder bénéfice a plus
que doublé après l'invasion d'ukraine
ont de quoi pourquoi ne pas taxer ses
profits exceptionnels de total plein de
députés sont 10 à cet été y ait des
amendements qui ont été déposés pas
seulement par la gauche aussi par des
députés renaissance qui sont dit bah oui
il faut les taxer ces supers profits
alors pourquoi le gouvernement ne le
fait pas mais c'est le malentendu dont
je vous parlais de ces pratiques ont
parlé de profiteurs de guerre nous
parlait bien sûr pas de total look est
bien entendu d'ailleurs regardez à quel
point le malentendu est énorme à
l'université du medef cet été bruno le
maire est invité et on lui dit mais vous
avez entendu parler de cette taxe sur
les super profits et lui dit quoi quel
super profil je ne sais même pas de quoi
vous parlez en écoute vous avez bien sûr
entendu parler de cette polémique aussi
sur les super profits non
n'étiez pas là cet été alors non mais
moi je ne sais pas ce que c'est que
super profits
donc non je n'ai pas entendu je sais
qu'ils entreprise doit être profitable
c'est tout ce que j'ai
créé cette phrase a marqué les esprits
sauf que la première ministre elisabeth
bornes si j'ai bien compris elle elle
sait ce que c'est et elle veut peut-être
enfin là
c'est la théorie du dauphin c'est la
méthode plutôt de la carotte et du bâton
dont on va dire la carotte c'est beau de
mer donc lui qui protégera des
entreprises des taxes et le bâton c'est
isabelle borne après tout est ce qu il
est pas un peu de gauche fin tout cas
elle vient de la gauche donc elle a dit
attention si vous ne faites pas un bon
usage de vos supers profits moi je vais
vous les taxes et ça a pas traîné ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que le
gouvernement décide de faire confiance
dans un premier temps exactement enfin
moi j'suis pas bordeaux olivier baron je
suis pas le porte-parole gouvernants
mais j'ai l'impression que ça veut dire
plutôt que de taxer des entreprises pour
donner l'argent à l'état qu'il
confierait son administration puis à ses
nombreux fonctionnaires ferait pas mieux
de laisser l'argent directement dans les
caisses des entreprises qui l 'ont
feront un bien meilleur visage
explications de roland lescure qui n'est
pas ministre la fonction publique un de
l'industrie lui je préfère que total
électrifie les bornes dans toutes ses
stations service je préfère que total
fasse des ristournes aux prix à la pompe
je préfère que total fasse de la prime
mâcon pour tous ses salariés plutôt que
de les taxer vous croyez qu'on peut
faire confiance à total je pense que
c'est l'objet de votre de votre débat
mais autorise dans l'air de bien
s'entendre patrick pouyanné et le
gouvernement puisque vous y avez été
d'accord avec ce que disait ben bernanke
dit bah oui regardez nous nos bénéfices
sont les réutilise ont d'abord pour
investir par exemple dans le
renouvelable ça sert à tout le monde on
va augmenter les salaires de
l'entreprise donc c'est un peu corporate
mais ça reste du collectif et puis il a
remercié le gouvernement merci bruno le
maire d'avoir une idée de nous tordre le
bras pour augmenter un peu c'est
ristourne sur le carburant on écoute moi
je veux dire c'est quelque part je
trouve que ça valide
l'initiative que nous avons prise sur
cette manche pas sûr j'aurais fait 20
centimes tout seul ce qu on était parti
sur 10 centimes s'il n'y avait pas eu un
débat avec le ministre de l'économie et
le débat qui était parti je pense de
cette assemblée donc je lui rends le
fait je trouve comme je lui ai dit
récemment la semaine dernier cette
semaine que finalement il nous a rendu
service puisque les français voient
concrètement la traduction des
superprofits de total énergie
directement à la pompe et il en profite
tant que c'est bien compris pas besoin
de les taxer ces super profession je ne
me mêle pas de votre débat vous allez
pouvoir en débattre juste pour préciser
que débat reste ouvert puisque au niveau
européen et bien l'union a décidé de
taxer les super profits des grandes
entreprises énergétiques ça devrait
rapporter 140 milliards qui seront
distribués par les tuyaux de l'union
européenne et puis si en france on faire
une taxe comme ça existe déjà en italie
comme ça existe en espagne et au royaume
uni on peut le faire les socialistes ont
déposé une demande de référendum
d'initiative populaire donc chacun
pourra essayer de mettre sa voix pour
avoir un référendum sur le sujet et le
débat est ouvert au débat merci pour ce
regard merci pour ce billet stéphane
comme chaque soir on va partir si vous
voulez bien de cette audition patrick
pouyanné je vais essayer de la résumer à
gros traits on en a passé un extrait
vous y avait évidemment assister le
patron total récuse la notion de super
profits il a expliqué que pendant le coc
vide il a pris ses pertes les cours
étaient bats et qu'aujourd'hui oui les
prix s'envolent 100 dollars en moyenne
le baril cette année et donc ils
engrangent alors il ya bien une rente
pétrolière pour total
mais at il expliqué la manne est captée
par les impôts perçus par les pays
producteurs de pétrole donc le
moyen-orient la norvège l'algérie par
exemple et donc il ya une activité en
france ça c'est le raffinage on pourrait
taxer cette activité en france mais il
explique que l'argent va directement
dans la poche des automobilistes grâce à
la ristourne à la pompe de ses bénéfices
fait sur le raffinage donc si je le suis
bien nous at-il dit ce matin et bien
cette taxe est pénalisante pour total et
inefficace pour les français est ce
qu'il vous a convaincu patrick pouyanné
est ce que vous comprenez ces arguments
genre là cazenave et ils sont très
objectif donc effectivement moi j'ai été
con q ce que dit le président de total
c'est que ces profits vont augmenter de
manière extrêmement significative au
niveau mondial et que roland doublé et
que c'est un pauvre ont doublé c'est le
chiffre qu'il a donnée maintenant il ya
des règles des 30 milliards
absolument mondiale son imposition ces
taxes vont doubler ce qui paraît tout à
fait normal après ce qu'il a expliqué
c'est que
ce que nous savons c'est que les impôts
sont territorialisée d'une part et
d'autre part il ne peut pas y avoir de
double imposition et on qu'on ne plaît
pas
en france on est assez pourtant que
mcdonald's payent des impôts en france
bon eh bien il faut être reconnaître que
total paye ses impôts aujourd'hui source
assure sa production de pétrole hélas
nous n'avons pas ni pétrole ni de gaz en
france où manière tout à fait originale
donc il paye ses impôts dans ces pays là
donc ils paient beaucoup d'impôts en
norvège et payent beaucoup d'impôts au
nigeria il paie beaucoup d'impôts au
qatar et en aidant les dans les miens
l' approche doit être européenne je
crois que il faut absolument que nous
ayons pour ces entreprises a donc on va
en parler mais donc si d'aventuré un
amendement fait fait sûr que la nuit
passe devant déposer un mais peut-être
même dans vos rangs au sein de
renaissance ou du modem de taxation des
superprofits vous votez contre c'est
clair et net provenant jeu chez eux dans
le débat budgétaire faut une approche
heureux très avis donc l'europe a décidé
deux contributions nous sommes d'accord
avec ses deux complices chaud il faut
que ces contrées encore squatté oui la
maison axa france c'est non pour vous
six mois qu'elle est en demande
tellement mon père oui alors on va
essayer de comprendre quelque chose
justement sur le contenu de cet
amendement christine hyper d'abord sur
patrick pouyanné aujourd'hui convaincus
ou pas absolument pas convaincu je ne
nous étonnerait pas
ce qu'il a ce qu'il a dit ce qu'on
savait déjà puisque ça avait été mise au
jour c'est qu'ils ne payent pas d'impôts
sur les bénéfices en france ces trois
dernières années ce qui nous a dit aussi
et ça je n'avais pas le chiffre c'est
que par contre il reçoit du crédit impôt
recherche 70 millions d'euros par an
donc moins le jeu autres explique à
nouveau le crédit impôt recherche qui
n'auront qu'un crédit d'impôt c'est quoi
c'est une comme son nom l'indiqué c'est
un crédit c'est à dire que même si vous
payez pas d'impôts l'état vous donne de
l'argent et en l'occurrence vous donne
de l'argent quand vous faites
de l'art et ses rôles dans la recherche
de la recherche ce qui nous a dit aussi
c'est que les raffineries françaises
avaient été moins productives que
d'autres raffineries notamment en europe
moi je on n'a pas pu allonger l'audition
mais j'aurais été curieuse d'avoir le
montant des investissements dans tous
les pays européens ces vingt dernières
années et savoir pourquoi nos sens nos
raffineries françaises sont moins
productifs et font donc moins de
bénéfices que d'autres
notamment européennes elles ont fait un
petit peu cette année les reconnaissait
que c'est compliqué de taxer uniquement
le raffinage parce qu'au fond le taux de
rendement fiscal de cette taxe tracera
décevants n'ont écouté le le référendum
l'initiative
partagé il est là pour j'ai envie de
vous dire poser le sujet sur la table
qu'il l'est déjà depuis bien bien des
mois mais
poser le sujet sur la table pour les
français alors il faut que ce serait
intéressant que les français puissent
s'exprimer il faut quand même un dixième
du soutien du corps électoral dans
l'hypothèse où certains projets de loi
ou proposition de loi référendaire pour
ceux qui nous regardent c'est de la
procédure c'est compliqué hein ce
nouveau droit constitutionnel tafer
voilà ça fait quand même qu'à lyon 8
voilà quatre millions
de francs sur neuf mois qu'ils peuvent
dire si oui ou non il faut taxer ces
supers profits en parle de total mais ya
pas de total 1 le référendum
d'initiative partagée 7,7
loi déposé elle ne vise pas que total
elles visent toutes les entreprises qui
font des super profits et puis moi j'ai
envie de dire à monsieur le maire qui
exactement le même langage que monsieur
puyané qu'on peut très facilement
expliquer ce qu'est un super profits et
en l'expliquent dans ce texte d'ailleurs
que je hais je les invite à le lire oui
il faut préciser donc il s'agit des
superprofits de de toutes les
entreprises de transports maritimes crpm
toutes les entreprises lors des
entreprises pour des super g et qui ont
un chiffre d'affaires supérieur à 750
millions d'euros c'est à dire des très
grosses entreprises et qui ont un
bénéfice supérieur à 25% par rapport à
une moyenne sur 3 ans donc vous voyez
qu'on est loin de taxes et un monde on
va lire sur la faisabilité de cet axe en
france mais votre sentiment votre
réaction à cette audition jean philippe
tanguy mais écoutez il faut juste
repartir un petit peu en arrière c'est
marine le pen qui en septembre 2021 à la
première a dit il ya des profiteurs de
crise et ensuite parler de profiteurs de
guerre ce que voulait dire marine le pen
à l'époque c'est que l'ensemble des
sociétés françaises en particulier
multinationale avait profité du plan de
relance des français des plans de
soutien pendant le risque au vide et
qu'il y avait des profits anormaux donc
illégitime parce qu'on avait une
économie qui était fragile et pourtant
un record absolu de bénéfices 140
milliards de mémoire pour
2021 alors que l'économie française
était fragile et la même chose pour 2022
d'eau qu'il faut déjà se dissocier de la
guerre ensuite il veut la guerre
malheureusement en ukraine qui
effectivement a amplifié la spéculation
sur les marchés energy l'énergie c'est
ce que disait monsieur macro même s'il a
reconnu après l'élection présidentielle
ce faisant le problème de ce que j'avais
dit et mes confrères et consoeurs
pourront le dire si j'avais dit qu'on a
fait cette commission d' enquête sur
total le prince est qu'en prenant total
on prenait un exemple qui n'était pas
représentative de tout ce que vient de
dire c'est à dire de la crise du coc
vide et de la crise et de l'ensemble des
profiteurs de guerre puisque total
effectivement comme l'a dit monsieur
cazeneuve de produits produits du
pétrole et du gaz en dehors de la france
et que les règles de taxation telle
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui après on peut
les interroger et j'en parlerai après
effectivement total donc vous
reconnaissez une forme d'impasse
j'avais dit au début on arrivera à ce
débat là c'est à dire qu'on constatera à
la fin bah oui total ne produit pas de
gaz et de pétrole mais ce que j'ai dit à
monsieur puyané cet après midi c'est
qu'il n'y a pas seulement la richesse
qui est créé par total dans les pays
producteurs total
cette richesse aussi parce que la france
forme des ingénieurs forme des cadres
commerciaux assurent la sécurité des
zones maritimes
donc total doit participer à l'effort
national doit contribuer à l'effort
national car la force en ce sens la
france sans les français sans les impôts
des français en taxant quoi alors mais
c'est la france total eh ben c'est qu'il
faut moderniser la façon dont taxe
aujourd'hui les grandes entreprise
monsieur cazeneuve la dia des principes
aujourd'hui qui sont obsolètes plus que
par la mondialisation par la répartition
de la valeur ajoutée ces règles sont
obsolètes et les france aujourd'hui sont
choqués alors parce qu'il découvre
qu'une très grande entreprise ne paie
pas d'impôts on va le voir il faut
revoir ça va et cd comprend quelque
chose lors des détails la filière
technique c'est ce qu'a mis quand même à
jour la commission c'est que totale
maîtrise toute la chaîne de valeur de
l'extraction du pétrole à la
distribution et donc ils font aussi
organise aussi la distribution de la
valeur ajoutée et donc du vieux où ils
font les bénéfices car il contrôler
toute la chaîne donc il faut aussi le
choix de mettre l'ensemble des bénéfices
avant que avant les activités qui sont
sur le sol français
organise une forme d'exil c'est ce que
font toutes les majors pétrolières alors
pour bien comprendre ce qui est possible
de faire ici à l'assemblée peut-être à
l'échelon européen je voudrais qu'on
s'arrête déjà sur cette notion de super
profit de qui parle-t-on et combien ces
entreprises ont fait de bénéfices nets
d'impôts cette année on va faire le
point avec maël morin on connaissait les
profiteurs mais les crises ont désormais
leur lot de super profiteurs les super
profits sont des profits exceptionnels
réalisés involontairement par des
entreprises qui bénéficient d'un
contexte extérieur favorable on commence
à entendre parler de super profits avec
le co vide 19 les grands groupes de
santé sont accusés d'engranger des
bénéfices considérables sur le dos de la
crise même situation en pleine guerre en
ukraine alimentaire transport énergie
les entreprises en tire des profits
record au premier semestre 2022 le
groupe angie a engrangé 5 milliards
d'euros de bénéfices plus de deux fois
supérieur à 2021 5,6 milliards d'euros
au second semestre pour total énergie
des bénéfices multipliés par deux et
demi 6 7 milliards d'euros pour le
groupe de transport de fret maritime cm
à cgm qui doublent lui aussi ses
bénéfices par rapport à l'année dernière
des gros bénéfices certes mais pas tout
à fait des supers profits selon le
président d'énergie c'est pas la
situation des jeans en matière de gaz et
angie achète du gaz aujourd'hui sur les
marchés de gros le revend à ses clients
en faisant une faible marge sur
l'électricité nous sommes cette fois ci
producteurs mais nous produisons en
france dans des systèmes dans lesquels
nos prix d'achat sont déjà fixés à
l'avance réponse du pdg de total energy
entendu par les députés c'est super
profits sont déjà taxés à l'étranger en
2020 avec le co vide les prix s'étaient
effondrés nous plaignons mondialement
cette année la plus basse 6000 6
milliards de divers impôts sur les
bénéfices et taxer la production fait
mondiale en 2021 nous en avons payé 16
milliards 8 milliards d'impôts sur les
bénéfices 8 milliards de taxes à la
production en 2022 nous périrons 30
milliards d'impôts et de taxes à la
production mondialement pourquoi parce
que dans la grande majorité des pays
producteurs où nous sommes implantés la
fiscalité s'adapte avec les prix du
pétrole donc en fait la rente pétrolière
ou gazière est captée par les pays où
nous exploitons les ressources
naturelles ou les produisons certaines
de ces entreprises ont aussi annoncé
reverser une partie de ses bénéfices au
profit des consommateurs dota l'énergie
par exemple a réduit de 20 centimes le
prix des carburants à la pompe
jean rené cazeneuve vous allez me dire
il faut faire ça au niveau européen
ursula von der leyen a fait des
propositions très concrètes mais
d'autres pays au niveau national on fait
alors pourquoi pas nous expliquez-nous
comment on fait l'italie le royaume uni
et l'espagne est ce qu'à un modèle qu'on
pourrait suivre la production donc
qu'ils peuvent
imposer la production et la maison s'est
présentée on a l'impression que la
france est un pays quand des millions de
kwh à la d'hydrocarbures l'italie
attrition d'hydrocarbures évidemment
l'angleterre la production
d'hydrocarbures évidemment donc ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'on a l'impression
que la france est devenue un paradis
fiscal à hurler de rire bon le les
entreprises en france paye des impôts
elle paye lourdement des impôts total
paye contrairement à ce qu'a dit madame
pires baudelle payent peu près deux
milliards de contributions et de taxes
diverses j'ai dit ici fallait-il impose
sur ce n'est pas parce qu'on
sait que le niveau de prélèvements
obligatoires et j'écris d'abord ont
baissé le ca river si vous envoyer ce
signal est là les mauvais pour toute
l'économie dès aujourd'hui dans la
moyenne européenne et c'est très bien
l'impôt sur les sociétés va rapporter
cette année 16 ou 17 milliards de plus
que l'année dernière et c'est tant mieux
c'est justement parce que nous avons
cette politique de l'offre on peut pas
non plus nous accuser de ne pas faire
payer l'impôt nous avons c'est nous qui
sommes à l'origine de l'imposition des
gaffes à haut niveau au niveau mondial
c'est nous qui sommes et ça a été fait
maintenant par niveau européen c'est
nous qui sommes à l'origine de la
position minimale de 15 % au niveau
mondial donc je voulais il faut surtout
pas imaginer que nous sommes contre à la
réponse elle doit très rhdp nous est
posée de quelque chose si elle doit être
européenne nous a sauvés je suis très
européen notre mouvement de dangerosité
très européenne et la réponse doit être
européenne elle a été articulé et on ne
déclinera en france si je comprends bien
les socialistes sont toujours très
européen aussi un il n'y a pas de
difficultés là dessus au fond pourquoi
vous vous alignez pas sur cette idée
d'une taxe européenne
elle a donné quelques éléments ça reste
assez technique et ça rapporte récents
40 milliards aux vingt-sept et on
imagine 33 % taxe et s'assure les les
superprofits elle serait calculée par
rapport à la moyenne des bénéfices des
derniers mois de toutes les entreprises
qui ont bénéficié de l'envolée des prix
et au delà de 20 % hop cet accès
pourquoi ça vous convient pas vous venez
exactement de décrire le dispositif du
référendum du texte que nous déposons
alors je sais pas si leur la commission
européenne avait lu notre rip avant
qu'il ne paraisse mais c'est qu'ils
aillent votre reee pelles et à quelle
échelle française
et à l'échelle française mais en jean
rené cazeneuve vient de poser de parler
de l'imposition minimale on en parle
depuis des mois et des mois et avant que
vous n'en parlez nous en avions déjà
parlé il ya bellion là on parle des
taxes non mais le 15 pour cent qui a été
décidé au sein des pays ocde puis début
les géants des les merveilles des mois
et années toujours pas en application
voilà donc ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que les super profits ont été
faits en 2021 ils seront faits en les
constantes rats en 2022 et que donc le
la proposition et l'amendement s'il
était voté lors du plf pour 2023 ou lors
du dernier ou des who du lors du dernier
projet de loi de finances de l'année
2022 par exemple parce qu'on aura cette
discussion là aussi permettrait
d'engranger des recettes tout de suite
et on a besoin de ces recettes parce que
ce que j'entends aujourd'hui c'est que
la réforme des retraites que veut faire
ce gouvernement elle est là pour
financer d'autres politiques publiques
mais avant de penser à ponctionner les
français et à écourter
notamment à allonger leur durée de
travail faire travailler que j'ai encore
basses sont d'abord à faire payer alors
moi je les appelle à profit
jean-philippe de leur visage elle attend
on a bien compris que les socialistes
soutiennent plus de tous les entreprises
vous avez permis je suis désolé monsieur
cazeneuve les entreprises qui font du
surprofit on est tous à coeur parce que
la situation est inflationniste
décorrélé de hal et innovation déco et
les deux tout investissement ces
entreprises là elle devrait avoir
ycompris pas besoin qu'on leur réclame
elle devrait le faire d'elle même alors
c'est aussi un sujet extrêmement
politique c'est un sujet symbolique
aussi dans ces temps difficiles
toutes les chancelleries d'ailleurs
européennes craignent un univers de
mécontentement donc il ya une portée
très très symbolique dans ce dans ce
dossier vous rassemblement national vous
aimez les référendum vous signez la
proposition de loi référendaire de de la
nuit baisse et du ps oui de ce que j'ai
vu je pense que nous pourrions la sni
tout simplement parce qu'elle reprend en
fait assez largement l'amendement que
j'ai déposée au pays les faire
oui où effectivement dizaine ont comparé
qu avec 2019 puisque c'est la dernière
année où l'économie était normal orco
vide et on disait tous les sites tous
les bénéfices pardon supérieure à 20% au
bénéfice de deuxième semestre de 2010
neuf devait taxer à 25% supplémentaires
pour les entreprises de plus de 100
millions d'euros donc il ya on est en
désaccord sur le barème des 100 millions
et 150 millions d'euros c'est si j'ai
bien compris mais le principe nommé sur
la contribution même exceptionnel vous
êtes vous êtes favorable il faut il
faudrait y aller a toujours été ça nous
plaît on compose en premier alors il est
pas là pour faire un combat de coqs mais
on va pas se dédire sur quelque chose
qu'on a toujours présenté par contre
nous on le re déposera un amendement je
pense qu'ils annulent ps le fera aussi
pourquoi car la difficulté du référendum
que vous proposez même si sur le
principe que je ne suis pas contre c'est
la temporalité le temps que ce
référendum se mettre en place et pour
peu qu'ils se mettent en place parce
qu'en fait même si on a les signatures
il faut encore que le parlement accepte
que ce référendum se tienne il faut en
réalité est un peu irréaliste or en loi
en cinquième des membres du parlement
soit 185 députés sénateurs et bien dans
les 140 et ensuite le conseil
constitutionnel a un mois et ensuite
neuf mois effectivement pour aller
chercher les quatre mis la pression mais
ruitz en 1509 savoir la démarche
parallèle wheels a maintenant mais ça on
est d'accord mais pas toujours tout ce
que je voulais dire c'est qu'il faut le
savoir qu en droit fiscal il est très
compliqué une fois que l'année fiscale
est passé d'aller rechercher des
bénéfices et des impôts sur ses
bénéfices après donc le temps joue
contre nous si on veut instaurer la
justice fiscale cas le monde mon
désaccord principal avec monsieur
cazeneuve c'est que c'est pas être pour
ou contre les entreprises les pme tpe pe
rubis sur l'ongle un impôt sur les
sociétés sans pouvoir optimiser
fiscalement leurs bénéfices sans même
pouvoir d'ailleurs bénéficié parfois par
signé par complexité administrative des
possibilités que le droit leur a offert
tellement c'est compliqué par rapport
aux multinationales ni d'égalité si vous
voulez juste un boulot fait que chacun
paie sa juste part jean rené cazeneuve
il ya des mois important dans ce débat
et qui sonne aux oreilles des français
comme une urgence la justice la
solidarité nationale on est dans un
monde de dix paires creed est ce que ces
mots là
vous les entendez et une contribution
exceptionnelle qui serait de courte
durée ce que vous pouvez l'envisager
après tout elisabeth bornes ne ferme pas
la part je le répète
nous appliquerons ce que nous allons
voter au niveau européen c'est à dire à
la fois
non parce que c'est une contribution
donc on pourra le faire dès ce plf et on
pourra le rendre concret des ce plf mais
elle répond se reconnaître taxi
européenne s'applique il faut bien que
les 27 fois d'accord non sommes pour une
contribution il est en transe et la
diffusion fiscales donc ça tombe bien
j'espère que ceux ci contre ce jeune
elle est en train soit trop ce que
voudrait ce sera une construction sous
quelle est la différence entre une taxe
est une contribution quand c'est qu'une
contribution temporaire on n'a pas
besoin de l'unanimité on n'a pas besoin
d'une éviter et donc le aujourd'hui on
aura à la fois ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
sur les producteurs d'énergie
renouvelable c'est que le contrat ont
été bien fait pour une fois c'est que
quand le cours était en dessous et pas
le coût réel était en dessous du contrat
eh bien on subventionnait ses
producteurs d'énergie et maintenant que
le court est au dessus pour lequel il
était garantie ils nous baladent il nous
paye la différence
mais ces bornes n'est pas l'air
complètement fermé à l'option mais je
suis pas sûr de me répéter dix fois la
même question je vais peut être une
réponse
les profits au dessus d'un certain seuil
pour tous les producteurs d'énergie
seront axés de mesures exceptionnelles
en france comme au niveau européen je
peux pas être plus clair que ça donc ils
seront taxés en france comme au niveau
européen et c'est normal et c'est normal
et c'est une mesure de justice mais nous
voulons des mesures ponctuelles
ont les moyens parce que fait
l'attractivité de la france
évoqué tout à l'heure il faut une
stabilité fiscale ce qui fait
aujourd'hui que notre pays a mieux
résisté que bo de beaucoup d'autres pc
parce que justement nous avons une
stabilité fiscale que les emplois
industriels reviennent en france que les
entreprises peuvent investir en france
donc on peut taper sur les entreprises
pour tel ou tel réseau mais à long terme
on le paiera très cher tanguay parce que
sur cette contribution européenne le
diable est dans les détails
malheureusement se désole c'est un peu
technique donc à 140 milliards d'euros
d'espérer bon ce n'est que 25 milliards
d'euros sur toute l'europe qui
correspondrait aux énergies aux
producteurs de fossiles gaz pétrole
d'ailleurs vous gagnez la nuit monsieur
puyané l'a dit ce matin est ce qu'il ya
très peu de raffineries donc en fait on
ne taxe sera toujours pas les surprofits
des pétroliers font les français
l'entendre voilà c'est essentiellement à
une taxe et c'est pour ça que nous y
opposera sur les producteurs
d'électricité or la limite que mes
lignes européennes c'est 180 euros par
mégawatt heure ce qui veut dire que les
français vont payer plein pot car le
nucléaire est à 50 euros l'hydraulique
est à 30 euros et l'éolien français
mettent à 80 euros donc en fait c'est
une taxe sur la production d'électricité
française pour payer les surplus de la
production allemande qui est le gaz et
le charbon qui sont toutes au dessus de
180 accord avec la les trains de spolier
les français et edf et donc un bien
public une fois de plus pour payer les
erreurs et les divagations des allemands
d'accord avec l'analyse des et sera le
mot de la fin parce que évidemment ce
débat il va se continuer dans le cadre
du budget on y reviendra moi je pour
conclure je dirai juste qu'on est dans
une situation inédite particulière du
jamais vu avec une inflation qui pèsent
sur les ménages qui pèse sur les ménages
et à côté de ça vous avez quelques
grands groupes mais pas beaucoup
quelques grandes entreprises qui elles
s'en mettent plein les poches et que les
français ne comprendraient pas qu'au
moment où on leur demande de faire des
efforts encore une fois ces grands
groupes ne soient pas mis à contribution
de manière exceptionnelle ce que je vois
depuis le début du quinquennat y compris
précédent c'est que et jean rené
cazeneuve l'a rappelé il ya le dogme
stabilité stabilité stabilité semapa
stabilité ces baisses on a appris les
caisses de l'état et ce faisant on a
augmenté le déficit parce que la france
en termes de déficit n'est
malheureusement pas la mieux placée en
europe alors on va pas vous mettre
d'accord c'est une évidence en tout cas
ce dossier se poursuit aussi bien au
plus haut niveau de l'exécutif qu'ici
même à l'assemblée où il ya une nouvelle
donne politique on verra ce que ça
donnera dans l'hémicycle merci
infiniment d'avoir participé à ce débat
vous on va à présent à accueillir notre
grand témoin il a été porte parole de
françois hollande en 2012 avant de
devenir son ministre de l'intérieur puis
son premier ministre il a créé la
surprise en cette rentrée politique en
lançant un manifeste pour reconquérir
les électeurs de gauche attaché à la
république
et qui ne se reconnaissent ni ans jean
luc mélenchon ni en emmanuel macron
socialiste de coeur depuis toujours il a
rendu sa carte la mort dans l'âme après
la constitution danube s aux
législatives bernard cazeneuve à nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant
après cette invitation signé stéphanie
des pierres
si on vous invite bernard cazeneuve
c'est parce que vous voulez refonder la
gauche sur les ruines du parti
socialiste depuis 2010 est plutôt
discret vous cultivez votre jardin les
roses sont votre passion et lo droi
votre métier socialiste depuis toujours
vous avez été un pilier du quinquennat
hollande son ministre de l'intérieur et
surtout son dernier premier ministre
aujourd'hui vous reprenez la parole pour
donner des coups de sécateur dans la
nuque baisse et démontrer qu'une autre
gaucher possible pas de concessions sur
la question républicaine une
transformation de notre politique pour
affronter les enjeux climatiques et la
volonté de faire en sorte que la
solidarité se construisent autour de la
possibilité pour chacun d'accéder au
travail et à la solidarité de se
manifester pour ceux qui n'ont pas la
possibilité d'y avoir accès parce qu'ils
souffrent du chômage pendant les
législatives déjà souvent côte à côte
avec françois hollande vous allez
soutenir les candidats socialistes qui
refusent l'étiquette nubes libération
vous a surnommés les papys flingueurs on
vous connaît nuancé modéré on vous
découvre incisifs contre vos anciens
camarades qui se sont alliés avec jean
luc mélenchon mais socialistes ont
déposé tous leurs bagages
sont précipités de façon nous tenir et
grégaire vers le grand méchant loup qui
menaçaient de les manger tout cru et ils
l'ont fait avec une solution
absolue début septembre
vous publiez un manifeste de dix pages
signée par 400 élus qui comme vous
veulent tracer un autre chemin à gauche
vous dit carrément que le ps est tout
tout viser un qualificatif qui fait
grimacer olivier faure le premier
secrétaire du ps j'ai trouvé que jean
afin que berlin 15 meur lapsus presque
révélateur c'était beaucoup
mélenchonistes ce qui m'intéresse ce ne
sont plus socialistes qui sont contre
tout le monde fatiha des espèces de
gauche qui n'aiment pas la gauche qui
aiment pas les causes écologistes qui
n'aiment pas les communistes une espèce
de gauche que vous êtes bien décidé à
fédérer vous lancez donc un mouvement de
réflexion pas encore un parti
bonsoir bernard cazeneuve soir merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation va parler de votre manifeste
dans un instant et de de la gauche que
vous portez au coeur que vous aimez qui
se retrouve orpheline a aujourd'hui pour
partie mais d'abord on a évidemment
envie de vous entendre sur la situation
internationale plus tendues plus
dangereuse aussi que jamais après le
discours de vladimir poutine bonsoir
richard vers l'histoire mais le chef du
kremlin s'est exprimé ce matin eh bien
oui myriam c'est le discours que tout le
monde attendait comment vladimir poutine
ce président qui a décidé de lancer son
armée à l'assaut de l'ukraine le 24
février justifie aujourd'hui devant son
peuple cette guerre et son éventuelle
poursuite alors que les conséquences se
font sentir dans tous les domaines on
sait que la russie qui est frappé de
sanctions économiques paix cette folie
de puissance au prix fort alors on
attendait cette réponse mardi soir elle
est finalement venu ce matin mercredi
sept mois pile après le début du conflit
et malgré les succès de la récente
offensive ukrainienne l'homme fort du
kremlin n'a aucune intention de reculer
plus préoccupant encore seule la
victoire est à ses yeux envisageable on
les écoute
afin de protéger la russie et notre
peuple nous utiliserons certainement
tous les moyens à notre disposition
ce n'est pas du bluff
alors ça ne vous surprendra pas mais
quand on écoute vladimir poutine annoncé
la mobilisation de tous 3 300 mille
soldats supplémentaires et quand on le
voit annoncer également l'organisation
de référendum pour annexer à la russie
les régions chrétiennes de louhansk
donne yates personnes et zappos ridja
des référendums qui vont avoir lieu dès
le 23 septembre du 23 au 27 une seule
question se pose pour les européens
jusqu'où aller c'est une question à
laquelle emmanuel macron a répondu par
anticipation mardi à la tribune de
l'assemblée générale de l'onu à new york
voici sa réponse ce à quoi nous
assistons depuis le 24 février dernier
est un retour à l'âge des impérialismes
et des colonies
la france le refuse et recherchera
obstinément la paix alors on l'a compris
pour le président français la diplomatie
reste encore une option pour aboutir à
cette paix que vous défendez aussi
bernard cazeneuve mais au vu de cette
escalade peut-on encore y croire il faut
y croire et lorsque l'on veut la paix
que la situation internationale est
aussi tendue qu'elle est il faut de la
persévérance de la détermination et du
sang-froid et tous ceux qui souhaitent
ardemment la paix savent qu'ils sont
engagés dans un combat au long cours
ce combat au long cours il faut le mener
avec de la constance la constance c'est
de continuer à aider les ukrainiens qui
montre une capacité de résistance et une
détermination à sauver leur propre droit
avantage on le fait on on l'a fait
depuis le début de la de cette guerre on
continuera à les aider bien entendu
c'est la position de la france c'est la
position de l'union européenne il ya les
sanctions à l'égard de la russie qui
sont destinés à minorer sa capacité à
poursuivre son effort de guerre ont
beaucoup de débats sur les sanctions sur
les conséquences des sanctions mais il
n'y a pas de solidarité qui se manifeste
à l'égard des peuples qui souffrent qui
n'ait de conséquences pour les peuples
qui manifestent leur solidarité
d'ailleurs il ya la diplomatie c'est à
dire que tout ce que l'on fait en
matière de sanctions tout ce que l'on
fait pour faire en sorte que la russie
n'est pas une victoire militaire totale
et pas de victoire militaire du tout qui
occasionne en ukraine des souffrances
considérables
doit bien entendu se faire aussi par
l'accompagnement d'un diplôme mais aussi
pour vous bernard cazeneuve continuer de
parler à vladimir poutine après les
annonces d'aujourd'hui
sont on peut toujours parler le dit me
recruter tout dépend ce qu'on lui dit et
si on part la lumière poutine c'est pour
témoigner d'une fermeté d'une
détermination la dîmière poutine et ces
événements le montre ne connaît que les
rapports de force sont si on s'adresse à
lui ce n'est pas pour tergiverser pour
manifester la fermeté appel à la
communauté internationale à mettre la
pression maximale sur le chef du kremlin
isoler la russie est-ce qu'il faut
prendre au sérieux la dîmière poutine
quand il menace à mots à peine voilés de
l'armé nucléaire contre l'occident ce
qu'il faut prendre au sérieux c'est son
cynisme
ce qu'il faut prendre au sérieux c'est
cette détermination à semer la guerre et
la désolation rien ne l'obligé qui
touche et à la sécurité de la russie qui
touche à la sécurité du continent
européen aux intérêts de son pays
enclenché cette guerre on le croyait
capable de recourir au nucléaire ou
cette fuite en avant de son échec je
crois capable de toutes les
manifestation de cynisme mais je pense
aussi que la détermination de ceux qui
sont aux côtés de l'ukraine est le
meilleur argument pour faire en sorte
que la menace reste à l'état de menace
et que les évènements aidant nous
puissions par le truchement de la
diplomatie retrouver les conditions
d'une solution françois hollande on s'en
souvient a toujours dit que poutine mans
échos poutine monte à continuellement on
va quand même été sacrément aveuglés par
le chef du kremlin pendant des années
comment vous l'expliquez comment vous
expliquez que personne n'ait cru à cette
invasion ou presque en france à part
quelques années tout le monde n'a pas
été aveuglé par vladimir poutine moi je
me souviens d'avoir été membre d'un
gouvernement qui pendant cinq ans a vu
le miss affaires étrangères le président
la république rendent compte ans et des
ministres de ce qu'était la relation
entre l'union européenne et la russie
lorsque le président la république a
décidé avec la chancelière merkel de
mettre en place
une discussion en schéma normandie il
l'a fait en ayant une lucidité parfaite
sur ce qu'ils étaient les intentions de
la lumière poutine et dans les
négociations qui se sont noués et qui
ont abouti aux accords de minsk il ya eu
de la part de l'union européenne de
l'allemagne de la france à l'égard de
vladimir poutine une lucidité qui s'est
articulé un discours d'une grande
fermeté et qui a permis à ce moment-là
d'obtenir des accords donc vous pouvez
pas dire que la france a été constamment
aveugle à l'égard non ça c'était il ya
dix ans il a toujours dit non il ya des
sensibilités politiques s'assure
toujours été
tendance à être pro russe qui ont
manifesté leur soutien de la dir poutine
qui continue à le faire alors qu'on voit
ce qu'est cette guerre la cruauté de
cette guerre ces leaders on les connaît
ils sont à la gauche de la gauche et à
l'extrême droite avec mélenchon le pen
on les connaît ils continuent de
soutenir ce régime lorsque j'ai
l'occasion de m'exprimer comme je le
fais ce soir c'est la part de leur
soutien sur les réseaux sociaux c'est un
déferlement de insultes et de haine mais
tout ça ne doit pas nous impressionner
ce qui compte aujourd'hui c'est que
l'action qui a été engagée et compris
par la diplomatie française par la
diplomatie européenne le renforcement de
la solidarité au sein de l'union un
moment le continent européen retrouve
l'horreur de la guerre c'est la
persévérance la cohérence pourquoi ils
le font c'est ses responsables
politiques que vous venez de citer par
antiaméricanisme par conviction ou par
simplement tactique politique en se
disant que peut-être poutine va gagner
qu'il faudrait mieux est de son côté
non je pense que tout dans leur
tempérament la conception qu'ils ont de
la politique
certains signes le montre dans nos
propres pays et
leur fait regarde avec des yeux de
chimène de régime autoritaire ce n'est
pas d'ailleurs les seuls régimes qu'ils
aiment il en aime d'autres en amérique
latine
moyen-orient
moi je me souviens d'avoir entendu jean
luc manche mélenchon expliqué que
boutines c'était merveilleux aux côtés
de bachar el assad qu'il allait régler
le problème de dèche on a vu comment
bouquiner des bachar el-assad a massacré
son propre peuple et vous seriez pas
jusqu'à dire qu'il ya du foot in
longeant le cochon non vous me posez la
question de savoir pourquoi il ya une
complaisance je pense qu'il ya une
complaisance parce que il y à un anti
américaines américanisme
viscérale et qui combinée à une baisse
de
mansuétude à l'égard des régimes
autoritaires jeu quand je dis ça je ne
fais un mot avant de parler de lagos et
de votre manifeste ce tournant dans la
guerre en ukraine il intervient en
pleine poussée des populistes en europe
et oui et oui les populistes en europe
les mouvements souverainistes nationaux
populistes ont le vent en poupe on l'a
vu en suède où les démocrates de ce fait
son maître part à 20% des voix on va
peut-être le voir dimanche en italie
alors j'étais moi même récemment au
meeting d'eugene de giorgia meloni la
leader de l'extrême droite italienne
crédité de près de 25% des suffrages ça
vous surprend cette poussée national
populiste et maintenant des
gouvernements qui sont prêts à basculer
et ce ne sont pas des petits pays comme
on dit sont des billets important
l'union européenne non ça ne surprend
pas parce que c'est un phénomène qui
vient de loin qui ne concerne pas que
l'union européenne ce qui s'est passé
aux états unis sous la présidence trump
est peut-être une poussée de fièvre
populiste dont on n'est pas sûr
d'ailleurs qu'elle ne se reproduira pas
ce qui se passe dans un salon de pays
d'amérique latine je pense notamment au
brésil c'est une poussée de populisme et
d'autoritarisme politique adossé à une
relation à la scion qui fit revivre le
nationalisme dans sa forme la plus
dangereuse et ce qui se passe en europe
et depuis maintenant un certain nombre
d'années et l'extrême droite aux
pays-bas en autriche en allemagne avec
l'afd en italie avec la ligue du nord en
france avec le rassemblement national
c'est un phénomène qui s'étend qui
s'était dans le paysage européen de
ville pourquoi pourquoi cela d'abord
parce que la mondialisation et l'absence
de capacité des états et des
états-nations à corriger les effets de
la mondialisation a engendré par tous
les phénomènes de relégation
territoriaux et sociaux qui ont des
conséquences sur les populations les
plus vulnérables sentiment d'abandon un
sentiment de déclassement une
impossibilité pour des classes sociales
et des générations de deux citoyens de
penser à un avenir pour leurs enfants
qu'ils soient meilleurs que ce qui a été
leur propre existence alors que nous
avions toujours vécu pendant des
décennies dans l'idée que le progrès
étaient possibles
la peur aussi de ce qui vient de
l'extérieur avec un processus de
reproduit mans et de repli identitaire
et puis une perte de sens des valeurs
c'est ça qui me frappe en france et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je mêle
aussi le combat politique que je mène
actuellement à la il n'y a pas de
possibilité de lutter contre l'extrême
droite s'il n'ya pas d'art dont
républicains essaient ardent républicain
ils doivent être solides sur leurs bases
au moment où il y a des forces de
fracturation magasin je vais vous
montrer une image oui cette image c'est
celle de la nuit baisse le jour de sa
constitution va la regarder ensemble
vous allez évidemment reconnaître tous
ces chefs de partis qui ont signé pour
cette alliance aux législatives où les
avez côtoyé pour certains d'entre eux
quand on la voit cette image qu'est ce
que vous ressentez c'est quoi ce sont
des traîtres
qu'est-ce que qu'est qui vous voyez pas
ce que ça vous fait quelque chose quand
même mais passons la gauche rassemblée
c'est la volonté de chaque socialiste
il n'y a pas de possibilité pour la
gauche de gagner signé par assemblée
mais est il y à des forces politiques
qui lorsque la gauche gouverner se sont
toujours employés à rendre son
gouvernement il faut c'est difficile
pour ne pas dire impossible en
organisant déjà la contestation de tous
contre tous look âge les difficultés
extrêmes moi je me souviens très bien
que lorsque nous étions à la peine
confronté à une crise terroristes et les
crises migratoires une crise de la zone
euro à une crise économique
il y avait les commentateurs qui à
l'époque
instruisez tous les procès
poussé la rue à la confrontation et
lorsque la grande manifestation du genre
zombie a été organisée alors que nous
étions en pleine crise terroristes
s'interrogeait sur le fait de savoir si
ceux qui étaient dans la rue eh bien
ceux qui devaient s'y trouvaient
et évoquant le fait que cette république
essayer de se rassembler autour de ses
valeurs étaient en réalité une
république de la relégation c'est une
force politique qui n'a aucun avenir
vous dites que je dis pas jean-luc
mélenchon toutes les chances de la
gauche de revenir un jour au pouvoir
aller au bout de mon raisonnement est
jamais la gauche sous françois
mitterrand sous léon blum sous pierre
mendès france ne s'est allié avec des
forces extrêmes qui sur la question
républicaine la question de la relation
à la démocratie la question de la
relation aux dictatures la question de
la relation à l'europe n'étaient pas
dans des positionnement clair qui
permettait de créer les conditions d'une
espérance jamais le parti communiste de
1980 n'était quand même pas il ya le
l'urss en arrière-plan mais lorsque
françois mitterrand s'est allié au parti
communiste il a une stratégie xtrac
exactement inverses de celles que l'on
voit prévaloir aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'il n'a pas placé le centre de gravité
de la gauche à ses marges il l'a placé
en son centre parce qu'il savait que
c'était là qu'était la capacité
d'abstraction d'attraction et de
rassemblement et n'a pas renoncé à la
relation euro atlantique il l'a affirmé
comme une priorité inapte à renoncer à
la dissuasion il a fait sienne il n'a
pas renoncé au projet européen il la
portait donc ce que françois mitterrand
a fait c'est par la force de son talent
de ses convictions
de ses valeurs de faire en sorte que la
gauche se rallient à ce que sa grande
tradition humaniste avait toujours porté
là nous voyons tous les jours sur
l'europe sur les dictatures sur la
république
sur
le travail des tas de propos de tenues
qui nous éloigne de ce qui est le coeur
de notre identité je vois fabien roussel
s'exprimer sur le sujet
je vois certains athées
mais je n'entends pas et socialiste et
je le regrette ça me peine je le dis
donc je ne les donnerai pas devant les
marches suffit qu'est ce que c'est que
ce mouvement de réflexion mouvement
politique aujourd'hui c'est le nouveau
nom pour les partis politiques
vous allez constitué quoi une force avec
des relais locaux pour créer une
alternative de gauche sociale-démocrate
entre emmanuel macron et jean luc
mélenchon pour 2020 c'est ça l'idée ma
conviction profonde est que la france ne
veut pas être le seul pays dans lequel
il n'existe plus de force de
gouvernement
et le spectacle que donne la nuque
baisse à travers ces débats quotidiens
ne me donne pas le sentiment que cette
force est arrivé à un stade de maturité
de conscience des difficultés auxquels
le monde est confronté est prête à
gouverner
spectacle le spectacle qui étonnait
quotidiennement aujourd'hui n'est pas le
spectacle d'une force de gouvernement
qui a pris la mesure des difficultés
auxquelles l'europe et le monde se
trouve confronté qui n'a pas pris la
mesure des politiques à mettre en oeuvre
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et qui tous les jours par le
petit bout de la lorgnette avec des
polémiques inutiles qui sont très loin
d'ailleurs des difficultés des
souffrances auxquelles les français sont
confrontés donne d'elle-même une image
d'abaissements d'objectifs
l'objectif c'est de faire ce que vous
attendez dès la campagne présidentielle
objectif est donc de faire la démarche
de long qui détient en politique de
d'avoir un niveau d'exigence qui
permettent de mettre le débat au niveau
auquel sont les enjeux carole delga ne
me fait pas partie de notre manifeste
de l'assigner elle a signé elle est avec
vous s'il a signé c'est qu'elle est
d'accord avec le groupe basque il ya
deux j'ai l'impression de stratégie ceux
qui veulent poser à l'intérieur du ps
sur la ligne et ceux qui sont à
l'extérieur je suis pas venu ici pour
faire des petits commentaires de prêt
sans intérêt excusez moi je viens pas
souvent la télévision c'était là bas ce
n'est donc pas pour cela que je suis
venu ce soir ce que nous voulons faire
ce que nous voulons faire c'est montrer
que face à la crise climatique face à la
crise démocratique face à l'éloignement
d'un certain nombre de forces de l'idéal
républicain
il y a encore des hommes des femmes dans
les territoires dans les clubs des
intellectuels qui sont prêts à mettre le
niveau d'exigence au niveau des défis si
déjà nous parvenons à faire en sorte de
parler à l'intelligence des français de
refuser
de convoquer tous les jours les
instincts de faire de la politique par
le seul truchement des réseaux sociaux
de faire en sorte que lorsque la
question climatique se posant sa
dimension
internationale européenne avec la
gravité que l'on voit on ne réduit ce
pas des solutions à la question du
barbecue que l'on met les solutions au
niveau des enjeux auquel on est
confronté le populiste et pas seulement
l'extrême droite mais le populisme n'est
pas seulement à l'extrême droite le
nivellement du débat politique par les
réseaux sociaux n'est pas seulement
l'extrême droite c'est une gangrène qui
s'est emparée de l'espace politique tout
entier et moi je suis désolé je ne vais
pas m'excuser
lorsque je m'exprime de vouloir faire en
sorte que le débat soit portée au niveau
des enjeux et je vais pas m'excuser de
respecter les français et de vouloir
parler à leur intelligence plutôt que
dans l'intervalle et sert aller au débat
qui semble occuper aujourd'hui toute la
gauche depuis maintenant deux ou trois
jours quand ce n'est pas ça c'est autre
chose et qui donne de la gauche et fait
du paysage politique français une image
assez triste d'en parler à
l'intelligence des français c'est aussi
les convaincre de revenir aux urnes
l'abstention et la crise démocratique
est très importante c'est le spectacle
qui est donnée actuellement est de
nature à donner envie aux français de
revenir aux urnes comment vous allez
convaincre et vous pensez mais les
jeunes notamment bernard gafner des
émissions sur les chaînes d'information
continue de céder baal fini et le
questionnement systématiquement le même
des acteurs politiques lorsqu'ils sont
hâtés aux questions sur la jeunesse sur
présidentielle et nature à conduire les
français aujourd'hui je vous allez une
jeunesse dans notre pays quand elles
continuent à voter qui attend d'être
rassurés qu'ils attendent des solutions
face au réchauffement réchauffement
climatique jeu face aux angoisses de
l'avenir notamment et qui quand on
regarde des enquêtes d'opinion se
tourner soit vers jean luc mélenchon
soit vers marine le pen en priorité le
mot de radicalité est ce que vous le
faites vôtre on l'entend beaucoup dans
cette danse à djanet former
10 et parlons à la diligence et france
et la radicalité c'est déjà existé dans
l'histoire politique de notre pays
lorsque les radicaux il s'appelait comme
ça par hasard décide de fonder la
république pour couper tout lien avec la
monarchie de mettre en place école pour
tous de séparer l'église l'état on est
dans une véritable radicalité mais cette
radicalité c'est pas un extrémisme c'est
un corpus de principes de valeurs qui
structurent une société avec la volonté
d'ailleurs de faire en sorte que cette
société trouve son unité et donc moi mon
problème c'est pas la radicalité quand
elle prend conscience des difficultés du
monde et s'inscrit dans une démarche qui
est destiné à créer de la cohésion et de
la force c'est l'extrémisme c'est
l'outrance c'est la violence verbale
c'est l'abaissement du débat c'est
l'appréhension de tous les problèmes du
monde ils sont immenses systématiquement
par le petit bout de la lorgnette c'est
ça mon problème vous avez un nom pour
votre mouvement
réfléchir collectivement mais ce
mouvement c'est un mouvement de
réflexion à ce que j'ai envie c'est de
sortir des appareils nécrosés c'est de
sortir de ces débats qui n'intéressent
plus personne c'est d'ouvrir les portes
et les fenêtres et de faire en sorte que
l'on puisse avoir dans des mouvements où
l'on respire où l'on se respecte moi je
ne participe pas l'excommunication quand
je dis ce que j'ai à dire sur la
république où ce que j'ai à dire sur le
réchauffement climatique ou sur la
politique énergétique
immédiatement le discours est le même
que celui qui s'adresse d'ailleurs à
fabien roussel si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec la ligne générale c'est
que vous êtes de droite ça s'appelle le
sectarisme
avec cette contrepartie qu'est
l'excommunication vous voulez
élus actuels du parti socialiste des
députés vous rejoignez 90% des
signataires de cette motion sont membres
de partis politiques du parti socialiste
des radicaux cetera donc moi parti
socialiste et ma famille je reste
viscéralement attaché à cette famille et
si j'ai pris la décision que j'ai prise
c'est pas parce que je voulais m'en
d'éloigner c'est parce que je voulais
que le fleuve retrouve son lit et
demeure fidèle à sa source comme disait
on va suivre on va suivre de près ce
nouveau mouvement de réflexion ce
mouvement politique qui qui veut
conquérir cet espace j'appelle tous ceux
qui ont entrepris s'inscrivent dans la
tradition
d'espérance à rejoindre ce manifeste et
à le signer pour nous aider à faire en
sorte que nous puissions retrouver voilà
un peu d'espérance voilà quelques
quelques pères fondateurs et spirituelle
qui sont qui sont cités vous restez avec
nos riches à bernard cazeneuve c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos a franchi pour
leur parti pris on va retrouver un
visage familier ce soir fanny guinochet
pour l'économie qui va nous parler du
premier texte dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée la réforme de l'assurance
chômage ça va clivé à n'en pas douter
puis un nouveau venu au journaliste
mohamed sifaoui et qui lui nous parle du
mondial de foot au qatar boycott boycott
nous affranchit les voici bonsoir
bonsoir à vous de fanny la gauche se
divise sur la valeur travail un ruisseau
roussel on a évoqué cela avec bernard
cazeneuve il ya un instant elle va sans
doute en revanche parler d'une seule
voix sur le premier texte qui arrive à
l'assemblée vous nous parler ce soir de
la réforme de l'assurance chômage oui et
si loin d'être une réforme très
consensuelles alors emmanuel macron veut
aller plus loin plus loin que la réforme
qui l'a déjà fait sur
l'assurance-chômage lors de son premier
quinquennat il veut atteindre le plein
emploi c'est à dire 5 % de chômeurs on
est à peu près un taux de 7 4%
actuellement et pour gagner ces deux
points une des solutions c'est d'inciter
les demandeurs d'emploi à reprendre un
travail beaucoup plus vite et ça tombe
bien dit il parce qu'en ce moment du
boulot il y en a il ya des offres
d'emploi
pléthore les chefs d'entreprises se
plaignent de trouver personne et le chef
de l'état veut aller vite sur cette
réforme alors l'idée de cette réforme
c'est de moduler les indemnités chômage
en fonction de la conjoncture économique
oui plus la situation sera bonne et
moins l'assurance chômage vous protégera
- vos allocations seront dureront seront
longues en revanche celle inverse s'il
ya un coup de vent si la conjecture la
conjoncture est mauvaise et bien là au
contraire vous serez nettement plus
protégés par le système alors c'est
quelque chose d'un peu nouveau mais les
syndicats ont déjà dit qu'ils étaient
tous contre pas question de faire peser
tout sur les demandeurs d'emploi c'est
une façon de les stigmatiser pour eux
c'est une mauvaise idée cette réforme et
puis cette idée elle est inefficace
parce qu'en fait qui fait que un chômeur
ne reprend pas un travail souvent ce
sont d'autres raisons ce sont des
problèmes de deux formations on n'a pas
les compétences qui correspondent au
poste vous bi alors des problèmes plus
matériel on n'a pas de garde de
solutions enfin garder son enfant pour
se libérer et aller travailler et puis
enfin c'est aussi une mauvaise idée
parce que un chômeur moins d'un chômeur
sur deux actuellement est indemnisé
alors concrètement en plus quels seront
les critères qui seront pris en compte
pour savoir si la situation économique
est bonne ou pas on voit par exemple en
ce moment que les économies sont un peu
déboussolés on a presque une croissance
qui faiblit presque jusqu'à la récession
ayant un temps on a un très bon niveau
d'activité et des offres d'emploi sur le
marché un mode commentaire vous député
vous lave autoriés cette réforme je la
voterai pas si elle est
présenté de la sorte par le gouvernement
si elle est conclue je la voterai
d'autant moins que il dit j'ai une
réforme de l'assurance chômage pendant
le dernier quinquennat
qui a eu pour principale conséquence de
précariser des chômeurs qui est déjà en
situation de très grande précarité près
de 800000
participer à la cour mais ça si vous ne
me tenez plus aucune indemnisation aux
chômeurs si vous mettez les gens en
situation de précarité extrême et vous
pouvez les conduire effectivement à
connaître à sortir de la précarité du
chômage pour connaître sa plus grande
précarité dans l'emploi c'est pas un
projet de société le vrai projet de
société c'est de faire en sorte que le
problème structurel du chômage
c'est-à-dire l'inadéquation entre la
formation dont bénéficient les chômeurs
qui est trop faible et les besoins du
marché du travail soit réduite et pour
ça il faut encore une fois misé sur
l'intelligence dire la formation
l'innovation
les ressources humaines et ça implique
que ce soit sur la formation que
l'accent soit mis énormément sur la
précarisation mohamed allez on va partir
au qatar avec vont là où là on entend
cette petite musique du côté des joueurs
sont appelés par notamment des des
comédiens très connus vincent lindon
pour ne pas le nommer à boycotter c'est
ce mondial de foot au qatar vraiment
menacer la coupe du monde je vous
rassure la coupe du monde aura bel et
bien lieu
on aura même des buts et probablement du
spectacle comme lors de chaque événement
de ce type mais il y aura probablement
des polémiques car tout sera scrutée et
c'est peut-être le seul intérêt à
confier un tel événement un pays comme
le qatar qui sera pendant un mois sous
les projecteurs on comprend ces voix qui
s'élèvent pour rappeler que les stades
seront climatisés une aberration
écologique
évidemment à l'heure où le simple
citoyen est culpabilisé lorsqu'il allume
sa lampe de chevet que plusieurs
milliers d'ouvriers étrangers aussi sont
morts dans cet émirat lors de la
construction des édifices érigés pour
accueillir l'événement mais aussi
évidemment pour souligner aussi les
nombreuses atteintes en matière de
droits de l'homme car le régime qatari
est connu pour fréquenter les
démocraties tout en méprisant leur
modèle de gouvernance
personnellement c'est un parti pris ma
main bon contre je vais d'abord rappeler
quelque chose d'essentiel certes le
régime piétine évidemment les droits
humains et surtout qui sponsorise les
mouvements islamistes notamment les
frères musulmans je n'ai eu de cesse de
le dénoncer pour autant soyons honnêtes
le qatar ne s'est pas autoproclamé
organisateur de la coupe du monde il y à
une attribution qui a obéi à des
modalités
pendant les quais pendant lesquelles des
états représentés par des fédérations
nationales qui ont voté il ya eu des
voix rien il ya un vote le qatar était
déjà entre guillemets un état suspecté
de suspecter et je dirais c'est un
euphémisme de ne pas respecter les
droits de l'homme et de sponsoriser les
islamistes alors ceux qui ont voté ont
préféré le qatar à 4 démocratie des
états unis d'amérique la corée du sud le
japon et l'australie cela devrait faire
réfléchir d'ailleurs les complotistes
qui pensent que l'amérique contrôle tout
non ceux qui contrôlent le monde est en
vérité et on le voit c'est surtout le
pouvoir de l'argent est souvent celui de
la coke de la corruption et des
compromissions
je ne fait que rappeler que des enquêtes
ont été lancées peau pour de sérieux
soupçons de corruption les états du
golfe pour ne citer qu'eux à rose il
faut le dire la planète depuis plusieurs
années or qui dit corrupteurs dit
corrompus donc avant d'appeler au
boycott il faudrait peut-être exiger
plus des tic et surtout demandé aux
hommes d'état de répondre à ces deux
questions qui me semble essentiel
premièrement peut-on considérer que
seuls les démocraties sont éligibles aux
grands événements sportifs 2 comment
agir face à céder à ces états anti
démocratiques voire voyous qui sont à la
fois nos alliés stratégiques militaires
économiques et qui sont parfois des
adversaires et biologiques voir des
sponsors dans un habitat intérieur un
véritable mode d'emploi c'est une forme
d'appel que vous lancez un sort alors un
noeud gordien a levé me semble merci
beaucoup merci mohamed sifaoui et merci
infiniment
bernard cazeneuve est revenu sur le
plateau de lcp à bientôt les affranchis
merci richard également très belle
soirée sur s&p votre soirée documentaire
commence maintenant la cage en
sacrifiant à demain
[Musique]